in this course you will learn how to
build an event driven system with react
and fast API an event-driven system is a
common way to set up software Antonio
from scalable scripts developed this
course we've published quite a few
courses from him and they're always
great so this is up let me explain you
first how it will work we will create a
delivery that will pick a product from
one place and deliver it to a customer
we need to set a budget and we need to
write some delivery notes like Peak to
pizzas
and deliver to customer
and that should be it let's submit
and this is the new page that we
redirect so this is the delivery and
this is the idea of the delivery we can
see it here also so this Json is the
object that we create
on our first submit so this object here
will change once we submit these events
so while we deliver a product
it may happen a lot of events so
starting the delivery increasing the
budget pickup products deliver products
and many more but I will keep this
events
very small because they can be a lot and
once I submit this
events this Json will change and this
progress bar here will
change like this for example when I
start the delivery
we can see that we have the first half
is in progress because now the status is
active so now we are delivering this
product so we haven't picked up yet the
products because we need to submit this
form so
when we pick the products we have the
purchase price so I'll put 20 here and
the quantity so we need two pizzas
let's submit
and now the Json changed and also the
the First Progress bar has been
completed
the status now it is collected and we
have purchase price 20 and quantity 2 2
so we have two pizzas and we want to
deliver it to the customer now when we
deliver to the customer we want to sell
it with a higher price and uh the same
two pizzas that we want once we submit
this
everything is completed here and the
Json has changed so the quantity is zero
but we have also a sale price and the
budget has increased
so this is a simplified app of course
can here can be many more events many
more States but let's see how uh do we
build the state in the backend for this
scenario so the main part of this
tutorial is to explain that we will have
events in our backend which we will
store them in the database and all these
events will construct in a redis cache
the state of the current delivery so the
state we show it here this is the
current state and this is built by all
these events in the back end so this is
the main concept that we will learn in
this tutorial and this will function
even if Radice fails what do I mean by
that so in case redis fails and we don't
have the current state in our cache we
still have all our events in the
database and once redis fails we will
reconstruct this object from the
beginning doing the same logic that we
did in every event so we will see how we
will do this in this tutorial now let's
start building wrap let's start by
building the backend with fast API and
let's connect also to the radius
database so the first step is to log in
in the redis cloud and here I will
create a new subscription
I'll select Europe here
and this is free
and the subscription name I'll call it
just DB
database
and I'll create this subscription and I
will create a new database here so this
is just a subscription that I call it
database
and the database name I'll call it a
fast API DB
so
we will use the ready stack here
I don't think we need anything else
make sure to get the password here
because we need to connect with
the database and I will create this
database right now so let's wait a
little
so the database is ready we have the end
point here and we are ready now to build
the backend with fast API but first we
need to download also another software
which is redis inside this tool will be
used to monitor the database because we
need to check the data that are inside
for the moment my editor pycharm cannot
see the
data inside the radius Cloud but this
software
is buy radius and we can connect it
connect here directly so we need the
host which is uh this one so let me copy
it
paste it here
and automatically it will set also the
port the other alias
the username should be default
so username is default
enter the password I will copy it here
and
I will paste it here
and do we have test connection so let's
add release database
and I think it is ready so if I go here
we can see that we don't have any tables
inside this database but we will create
it with a fast API so let's create the
uh
[Music]
empty folder here fast API and I will
create a file
called Main
dot Pi the first step here is to install
fast API so pip install
fast API I already have installed it in
my machine and we will import it here so
from Fast API we need to import fast API
and then we will create the app which is
equal to fast API like this and that
should be it for creating a basic app
that does nothing but we need to add
some endpoints later
uh one other thing which is important
because we will use
also react front-end we need to import
fast API middleware
course
and we will import the course middleware
why do we need this
old paste also this code so we will add
the middleware course middleware and we
will allow this origin which will be our
react app so we need this because
our backend will random Port 8000 and
our front end will run on Port 3000 and
we will have problems if we don't add
this line so they won't communicate with
each other if we add this middleware
our react up will successfully connect
with our backend and that should be it
now let's connect with redis so for that
we need to install a package uh pip
install
radius
om
so this package
is useful for connecting to the radius
database so from redis
om
we need to import get ready connection
and
the radius connection here will be equal
to get redis connection
and we need to add some values which the
first one is host
and let's go to our Cloud here and uh
I'll copy again the public endpoint and
I will paste it here I will cut the port
here because we need another value here
which is a port
and will be equal to that port
then we need the password
which I will copy it here
and we don't need to add the the
username because it is a default
username and we need also another value
which is decode responses to true
and that should be it so with this
we may connect successfully to radius
but we have to test it to test it open
the terminal and write UV corn
make sure also to install a UV corn in
your machine
main up
reload
so we don't have any errors which means
this redis connection here it is
successful and now let's add the models
that we will work in this app so from
ready so M we need to import also the
hash model
and let's create
a glass here
I'll call it delivery
and this will extend from the hash model
and this object
I will add only two properties the
budget
which is an integer
and by default I will initialize it with
0 and the notes
which is a string
by default empty
and to connect this model with the
radius database we need to add here a
class meta
in the database
will be equal to Radice
and that should be it for this model
I will save it not sure if radius inside
will create something here let me
refresh
so we need to create objects in order to
see it so we don't have any objects
and let's create the second one that we
need which is the event so I'll copy
this
paste it here and I will create the
event
so uh this will be the main object we
need the delivery object just for the ID
so we will create it in the beginning
just to get the idea of this uh delivery
and we will work only with events and
this event will have the delivery
ID
which will be a string
and by default it will be none
window type
so this is the event type we will see it
later how we will use it which is a
string and the data
which is a string so the data will be
the Json or the body that we will send
in the request
and that's it so we created two objects
and now we need to add the endpoints
that we will work
so let's create the first one which is
the creating a delivery so I will create
here I will add a decorator up
this will be a post request to
the endpoint will be
deliveries
create
and let's add the synchronous function
here
def create
this will have a request
as a request
so let's import a
in the first API here also the request
and I want to get the body of that
request so body is equal to a weight
request
Json
and with that Json we will create the
delivery so the delivery
will be equal to a new delivery
with a budget
which be which will be equal to body
data
budget so why will
uh why we will we have this data in
front of the body
I'll explain it later because
all the requests will have the same
format and because they have the same
format all the parameters will be inside
the data key and that's why I will
create it like this
and the same will happen for the notes
so notes will be equal to
body data and notes
and in the end I will save it
for the moment let's return this
delivery
and let's see if it works and to test it
let's see if UV corn is running it is
running
let's open Postman
and let's make here a request a post
request to
http
localhost Port 8000 slash deliveries
create
and in the body
we will have this
Json so we need to type
which for the moment we don't use it but
this will be the request
and the type will be create
delivery
it will make sense later why we need
that type and we need the data
which is an object that will contain the
budget
uh 50 for the moment and the notes
which is uh
pick two pizzas
and that should be it so this is a
format that we want in every event if I
send this request
I get this response so I get the budget
I get the notes and I get also a primary
key so this uh is the idea that is
stored in the radius database if I open
Reddit is inside now I will refresh and
we have now a value here if I click here
we will see also the fields so we have a
primary key a budget and the notes so as
we can see we can monitor the database
with this software so
we created a delivery but this is not
the main part of our app we want to
create the event which is a the focus of
this tutorial so uh with the delivery I
will also create an event here
which is equal to event
and this level delivery ID
which is equal to this delivery primary
key like this
uh it will have a type
so
the type will be stored in the the event
object so type here
and we need the data as they are so data
will be equal to
I can use here
body.data but since the data here is a
string I need to
convert it from a dictionary to a string
so I need to use here Json
uh dump
string like this
and don't forget to import Json on top
and with this we will store also the
event in the database and let me return
the event here
and let me send this request again send
it and as you can see we created the
event which has its own primary key the
delivery ID of that delivery that we
just created the type and the data
as a string but it is a Json inside and
also in the radius inside we can see
that
we created the delivery but we didn't
create the event because I forgot to add
save here
so my bet there
let me send it again
and if I check it again we will have the
event object here which has its own ID
delivery ID the type and the budget so
this event table will contain all the
logs that all the events that happen for
this delivery so it is really important
now we stored these objects in the
database but this is not enough so
the response that we return here is the
object that we store in the database but
we have to return something else so we
have to return the
state of the delivery so this is a
delivery object in the database and this
is the event but we have to combine both
of those to represent the actual state
so it may be confusing for you for the
moment but you will understand it uh
more
once I add more code so I will create
here
uh
python file I'll call it uh
I want to call it events
but this will be confusing with the
actual event here so I'll call it
consumers
it is the same
but I just want to avoid confusion and
here I'll create a function which is
create delivery
and this function will have two
parameters state
and an event
so
you may be already confused here
this is a function that we will use
let me use it right now here to
construct the state that we want to
return so the state will be equal to
Consumers
create delivery
so this function we will pass the actual
state but the actual State for the first
event so the first delivers create is an
empty object because we didn't create
anything yet so the first parameter here
is an empty string and the second one is
the actual event that we just created
here and this function will return the
a state that we want in the front end to
handle and I will return it here
and what will be that state
for the moment it will be very simple
I will return
the
budget
which is a
uh actually I will get the data here
which is equal to Json
load string
event dot data
uh we need to pass the data that we
store here which is
this data here
and the budget will be equal to data
budget
I will cast it as an integer because we
may have problems later on with uh
these types
we need the nodes
which is equal not equal it is data
notes
and we need also the
another value which we don't have it for
the moment which is the status
so the first time that we created
delivery the status will be ready
so this is an extra value which I will
front end won't provide but we need this
value in order to track the delivery
and this will change once a different
event happens and
it is a the best way to do it like this
instead of just updating it from the
front end or any or any other way
also I forgot also one other value which
is the ID of the
delivery so this will be event that
delivery ID like this
and that should be it so this is the
state that we want to build and it it is
almost similar with the value that we
returned here but it will change a lot
and we want to be able to maintain this
structure
so let's test it we pass the state
parameter here but we don't use it but
it's okay because this is our first
event in the other events we will use it
every time
and if I send now the request
we will get this response so it is
almost similar but we have a status now
and this object will change a lot
and now we need another endpoint to get
the status of this delivery so
this is a post request we update the
status here but we need another get the
request to get the current status and
for that I'll create another function
actually I will create it here on top
this will be an asynchronous function
get
state
and this will have a primary key as a
string as a parameter
and
this will be
a get request
to
deliveries
with the primary key here
and status
but how do we get the status so this
state that we just created here
here we won't rebuild it again and the
best way is to get it from redis so we
should add also another line here that
we need to store the actual state in the
reddish cache when we save the objects
here we save it in the radius Json
database so it is a database just like a
mongodb
but if you if we use the radius object
directly like this we will store it in
the radius cache so uh that's why I
chose it like this it is a benefit of
using also the radius cache and also the
radius database just like mongodb
now when we set
the value in the cache we need a key and
a value so the key will be
deliver it
and we need to pass the delivery ID here
and to pass it I will add an F here not
here here
and I will pass
the delivery
primary key here
and the value will be the state but this
state it is an object so I have to use
Json dump string the state
and that should be it so be when we
create the state we will store it in the
cache and return it and when we get the
state here we will do the opposite so we
will get it from the cache so state
is equal to radius
get
I'll put an F here
delivery
with the primary key
and
I will return
Json
string the state because the value that
we stored is a string and we will get
also a string here and we want to return
an object or a dictionary
and that should be it this endpoint
won't work because we haven't stored
anything uh in radius so I will
add another get request
this will be
the get request to localhost 8000
deliveries we need this idea that we
just created
I'll pass it here and status
send it and we get an error because I
think
this value here is none when we don't
have anything
and
let me do it like this if
state
is not known
we return this value otherwise I will
return
just an empty object but this will
change later so for the moment I will
just put it as an empty object
and if I get the value here
so I need to
restart your record
I get an empty object because I need to
create another object again in order to
be saved already so I'll create another
object I'll copy the ID here
I will paste it here
send it and we get the value
so it's not looking good
because instead of dumping the string I
need to load the string so my bad here
and now it looks better so
this endpoint will get the current state
of this delivery every time
now we want to add another event that
just changes the status from ready to
active so let's do it now I will add
another endpoint
which will be similar to this one
so this will be
think
a death
I'll call it a dispatch
and this will have a request as a
request just like this one
and this will be
a post request to just
event
and what do we want to add here
so this delivers create is similar to
this one the only problem that we need
another endpoint for the delivers create
is that we don't have a delivery ID
and we create it here but here we have
the delivery ID in the event itself
actually let me create the event
so I'll duplicate the tab and this will
be event here
and in the body will be
the type will change now instead of
create create delivery it will be start
delivery
and in the data we don't need to send
anything so it will be like this so this
is the event that we will send and all
the other events will be sent through
this endpoint so the only the type will
distinguish the behavior and the data
and now let's go here so how do we
change the status based on this
information
the first step is to get the body to
parse it
and we need to
create the event in the database just
like we did here
so we are missing the delivery ID so the
delivery
ID will be equal to
a body
delivery ID
so this is something that uh
I should add because I forgot so we need
the type we need also the delivery
ID here which will be
uh this one
so my better
these are all the informations that we
need
start delivery delivery ID and the data
and now
we created the event and now we need to
manipulate the state how it will work so
the first step is to get the current
state and we will get it like this so
state
will be equal we have this function get
State here
it will be equal to 08 get underscore
State and we need to pass the delivery
ID there
we need a width because this is an
asynchronous function otherwise it won't
return what we want
and this state for the moment will be
this value so this is what do we want to
get and based on that state we need to
just change the status from ready to
active and we can simply do it here
state
let's say
it is a status it is active
but uh it won't work like that so this
is not the right way to do it we need to
create another function in the consumers
here
start delivery
which will accept the state and the
event
and the this time we will just update
the state
uh we can do it like this state
status is equal
to
active but I prefer this way so I will
return here
the state always a pipe here
and I want to change the status to
active like this
so
this operator will update
this value to the this new value
and that should be it so if I go to the
main.pi file
the new state now will be equal to
consumers
start delivery we will pass the current
state and the event which momentarily we
won't use there but it doesn't matter
we need to save it to reduce
so delivery primary key here is delivery
ID
and we need to save the new state and we
need to return the new state
so
that's it for this event we need we
still need to make some changes but
let's test if it works so if I send this
event
I will get the same object but now the
status is active and now if I send also
the same request again here the status
is active as you can see the status of
that delivery has been updated now it is
uh driving let's say so
this is how it will work but there are
some problems here
which is this start delivery
we added the endpoint to the event here
so we don't know if it is star delivery
or another event so we need to create a
general way to call the function based
on the type so the type is a
start delivery in our case
how do we do that so
I'll create now here a constant
I'll call it consumers
and this will be equal to an object that
will be mapped like this
create
underscore delivery
which will be the type
will be mapped to the create delivery
function
like this
and start delivery
will be mapped to the start delivery
function
so why do we need this constant
we need this constant now because
we can change now the start delivery
to consumers consumers constant here
we will pass
the type which is this body type or
event that type so I'll pass event that
type there
and we will do the same thing so the
same will happen for the create deliver
here so I will do it like this
and this is a dynamic way of calling
different function based on just the
type
so right now we don't know if we are
calling uh
start delivery or another event that we
will create later so let us try this
event so I'll create another delivery
sent Ando indeed it works so I will copy
this new ID
paste it here
and it works the status is ready now if
I go to this other event I will paste
the new delivery ID here
send it and now the status is active if
I send the request here
the status is active so
this is the dynamic way of calling
different consumers
now the structure is ready and we can
add the easily multiple events so let's
add another one so here we made the
status active I will duplicate the tab
and now we will send another event and
this time will be pick up
products
and the delivery will be the same
and in the data property we will send
the
purchase
price
which will be 20 and the quantity
which will be 2 in our case so we want
to send this event and we don't want to
do anything here so this is ready this
can handle multiple events types and the
only thing left that we need to add is
to add the consumer here so we need to
add I will create the function
uh pick up
products
this will accept a state and an event
and that's it so it has become really
easy to add multiple events this is a
pickup products
and this is a
pickup products
so
we easily added one event let's handle
the case in our function now what will
happen when we when we get this event so
first I will copy this part I'll get the
data
from the vendite data
and
I will return in the end the state
the pipe here and these are the things
that will change it will change the
budget
it will decrease
so I'll put an empty value for the
moment
we will add the purchase price
which will be data
purchase
price
I will cast it as an integer
because we may have problems
we need also the quantity
and this is a quantity here
and also the status will change
it will become collected
so let's also calculate the budget so
the new budget
I'll add it here new
budget is equal to state
budget
minus
the purchase price times here the
quantity
and that should be it we will assign the
new budget here
and it is ready so this is almost
completed so we will add later
validation but for the moment this will
work let's try to send the request and
it worked as we can see our budget
decreased we the status changed and we
added two new properties and if we send
the request we will get the new updated
State here so it is working fine and now
we can add also the last event which we
can complete this
uh delivery I'll duplicate this and this
will be delivered
products
and uh
here instead of purchase price we will
add sell
price
and that should be it so let's add it
here also this will be almost similar
let's add the function deliver
products
with the state and the event
and let's add it here
deliver
products
and inside here
actually I will copy the code here
because it is almost similar
so we will get the data from the event
and now our new budget it will be our
budget Plus
the not purchase price but sell price
here
this is also sell price
the quantity also will change so I will
add a new field here new quantity
is the old quantity which is state
quantity
minus
this value
and here I will add the new quantity
and in the end the status will be
completed
so we will complete the delivery here so
it is the same as this one but we will
increase the budget we will decrease the
quantity and we will change the status
and that should be it so deliver
products sell price quantity everything
is correct let's send this event
and it is working fine as we can see the
status has changed the purchase price
and the sale price are the same and the
quantity has been decreased to zero so
everything is correct we added all the
events and this is the best case
scenario so what do I mean by that every
event that we send has been successfully
executed and we didn't have any edge
cases
uh when we create an event-driven
architecture sometimes we may send
events that
should not when it should not be the
time or we can send errors so we should
have a lot of validation using these
events
for example when we start a delivery
what happens when we send it again the
delivery is already active we should
throw an error like
the delivery has already started
or what happens when we purchase
products and we don't have the budget
for it so let's handle these edge cases
the first step is to create another
event and this time I will change the
notes Here we will pick three pizzas but
we won't have the budget for it because
one pizza is 20 and the budget is 50.
let's send this request and it worked
fine now I will copy this ID
I will add it here
and I will start this delivery but
before I send the event I'll add a
validation here and the validation will
be for the status of this uh delivery
so here I will add a new condition if
state
that status
is not
ready
then we will raise an exception
because we cannot make the delivery
active once it's already gone or it has
another state so only when the state is
ready we can change the status to active
and here I will raise an http
exception
so let me import this
so the HTTP should be uppercase
and we need to import from a fast API
HTTP exception and here the status code
I'll make it 400.
and the detail is
delivery
already
started
and that's it for a simple validation so
if we have this validation
when we post it the first time to start
the delivery
we will make it active so this is
correct but when is when we send it the
second time
we will get an error delivery has
already started we cannot start it again
so that is the simplest validation and
we can add more complex validations like
this budget here so we decrease the
budget but what happens
if the budget so the new budget is less
than zero so we don't have the budget to
purchase the products so I will raise
another exception here
and the status code will be the same and
here I will say
not enough
budget
and that should be it so the delivery
has already been started I'll copy the
delivery ID
I'll paste it here the purchase price is
20 and the quantity will be three so
this is this will be more than the
current budget which is 50. let's send
this request and we get the error not
enough budget and now uh
it will become like a tree so in this
case we may have multiple choices to
solve this problem
we may increase the budget so
uh we should buy those three products
or we may buy two products and deliver
less products to the customer so as you
can see with this approach we can handle
many cases many decisions handling all
these cases using the traditional way of
rest apis it is very difficult but in
this way we can handle every case
so what will we do now so we will handle
both cases and I will add now another
event which is increased budget so
increase
budget
this will have a state
and an event
and I will add it here also
increase
budget
and what will we add here so it will be
very simple we will get the data from
the event and now the state
budget
we will increase it with the
data
budget
like this and we will return the state
so it is super simple
and let's add it also here so let's
duplicate this let's add another event
I'll duplicate tab
let's copy the delivery ID
and this will have only the new budget
so we will
increase
the budget
with uh by 20 here so let me send again
the event so if I send this event I will
get not enough budget maybe I have an
error here
so yes not enough budget but if I
increase the budget
we can see the budget now is 70 and if I
send this event again
the transaction will be completed and
the status will be collected so we got
the three pizzas we can deliver these
items now to the customer so
I'll paste it here and the sale price
will be 25
end of the quantity will be three let's
say the quantity is four so we make
another mistake here so
here we can add another validation just
like we added the validation with the
budget here
but this time is the quantity so if the
quantity is less than zero
we can say not enough quantity or not
enough quantity I will
I will make the message
so if we had this validation
this won't work as well because we will
we are selling more products that we
currently have so it should be three
and now everything is completed so
that should be it this is the case when
we decide to increase the budget but
what will happen if we decided to
deliver less products so let's do it
right now I'll create another delivery
I'll copy the delivery ID
and I will start this event
and now I will
uh pickup products here
and I'll get this error which says not
enough budget
and this time I will decide that I will
deliver less I will buy less products
and it's it it is working but as you can
see in the notes we have big three
pizzas and the quantity is two
and we can go now to the customer and we
can deliver the the products which in
our case we cannot deliver three anymore
but we will deliver two of them
which works but
is the customer satisfied or not so we
may go to another decision tree here so
the customer may accept less products or
the customer may want the other product
next time or the customer may refund the
order so either three products or none
of them so there are many decisions that
should be made here and I will not
handle all of them you can understand
now how this architecture can help us
handle all possible validation and all
possible scenarios
when we have an event-driven
architecture so we are finished with all
the events and all the apis but still
there is one case which we didn't handle
so what happens when a radius fails so
in this case here as we can see uh we
are getting the products from redis and
I will copy again here the deliver ID
paste it here
and the status is completed but this
status is the aggregation of all the
other events that happened here
in case redis fails our system should
should be the same so so it should
return the same value here but how do we
do that the way that we can do that is
by rebuilding all the events from the
beginning so we have
a log of all events that happened in
this app so I will refresh here and we
have a lot of events so here in a radius
inside I can filter with main dot event
column star here and here we will get
all the events
we should filter all by this delivery ID
but it doesn't matter we should get all
the events from the database and we
should recreate this uh State here so
let's do that now I will comment this
part and the state for the moment is
known let's say that already returns
none here and if that is the case
if I send this event I will get an empty
object which is this one so here now I
want to do an algorithm that will return
the actual state
so that the
function I'll create it here I'll call
it build
state
and this will have a primary key as a
string
and I'll call it here so the new state
will be equal to build state with the
primary key and we will return it here
so this is correct here the only thing
left is to build the state here so let's
complete this function the first step is
to get all the records so
radius Json has this function event
all primary keys unfortunately there is
no other function that returns all the
objects so this is all we have
but we can manage to do what we want
with this function so we got all the
primary Keys now all the events
will be equal to
uh
something for primary key in primary
keys
so
uh this something here will be event get
primary key
so this will return all the events as
objects
actually
let us do it like this so first let's
return all the primary keys
so we can see how it works step by step
if we do that
let me start this
if we do that
we will return all the primary Keys like
this
and if we do the Second Step I will save
it
we will return all the events
of all the
product all the deliveries
so it is working fine but we want only
this delivery ID so we need to make
another filter here
events will be equal to
something here
for event in
all events
with the condition
if events that delivery ID is equal to
this primary key that we pass here
and this will be just the event like
this
so this is a filtering that we want to
get all events for this delivery if I
return it here
I'll save it we can see that this
delivery ID is different from the first
and the second
event if I send the request now
all the delivery ideas will be the same
so these are all the events for this
delivery
and that should be it so we got all of
these events and now what do we want to
do how do we rebuild the state
as it was in redis uh
now the way to rebuild the state is to
redo everything from the beginning
I will make a for Loop now for event in
events
and for each event
we will
build the state so the state
will start as an empty dictionary just
like we did when we create a delivery
here
and for each event in the events the
state will change and the new state will
be consumers
consumers again
so it will be this function here
I'll not pass here an empty object but
this will be the actual state
and that should be it we will start with
an empty state
we will pass the first event which will
be create the delivery and we will
update the state and then we will go in
the next event
and this will change the state again and
again till the end where we will return
the updated State and this state will be
the state that we want so this is how we
rebuild the state
uh I will save it let's see if we have
any errors we don't and let's send again
this request
so we have an internal server error
care budget
so I think I know the problem when we
return the events
I will save it
and when I return the events I see a
problem here is that the order is
different that the order that we want so
what the what should we do right now
uh to be honest I'm not sure why is it
that it returns in this order I think
they are ordered by the primary key
which should not be the case they should
be ordered by the creation time so uh
it is the order is totally random so the
only solution that
I can find for the moment is this one so
the first one is create delivery
and I will get this primary key so I
will
make it manually
but it should work
in every other database it should work
normally so we should get all the events
in the normal order then it is a start
delivery this is the second one
the third one is pickup products
and the last one so not pick up products
here so my bad it should be this primary
key and the last one should be the
first primary key
and if we do it like this
we will get other events in the correct
order and now
let's uncomment this part
let's get to the state
I will save it
send a request and this is what we get
so this is the result that we wanted so
everything works fine except this get
all primary keys for some reason it
orders the primary Keys alphabetically
but they should we should get all those
values based on the creation time so
this is a small bug but I guess
um it's not a problem you get the idea
how it works now I'll get the state from
redis
just like we did before and if the state
is known uh is not known we return the
state directly if it is known we will
rebuild the state and we will save it
again to radius here
so we want to rebuild it again and this
is just the primary key
and this is the function so if I send a
request now I'll get the exact same
result and that's it uh this is how we
handle the state in the backend now it's
time to build the front end
now let's create the front end so I will
open a terminal here and run MPX create
react app I'll call it react events
and let's wait till is completed
so it is completed and now I'll open it
with my IDE here I'll run npm start so
we can
start our react up on Port 3000 so
it should work fine so now it is running
now let's install bootstrap for this
project I will install it directly
through the terminal so npm installed
bootstrap
so it is installed and I will go now to
our app.js
I will remove these Imports we don't
need the app CSS
or delete it
even index CSS actually I will just
remove the code here
I will remove a
test.js file
and in our app.js I will simply import
bootstrap here
this CSS bootstrap.css
so
we will get the bootstrap here let's
also remove what we don't need here
and it will look like this so this is
just a blank page I will go now to
index.html
and here
in the body I will add this class so I
want to make the background dark so I
will add this class here
and now it will look like this uh then
in our app.js
I will remove this code and I will
replace with this code so
this won't change anything but if we
want to add now a card which I will add
so
I'll add div here with a class name of
card
then inside I will add another div with
a class name of a card header
I'll add here create
delivery
here I will add the form
with the class name of
card body
and inside now we can have inputs so I
will add the
another div here
with a class name of
input
uh just margin bottom three
and another input here
this will be a type of
number
name will be budget
class name
will be
form control
and the placeholder will be budget
so I'll copy this paste it here and we
need another input but this time it
won't be a type number this will be a
text area
and uh this will have the name of notes
form control here and this will be notes
and that should be it let's add also a
button here
with a class name of
BTN vtn primary
submit here
so this will look like this so we have a
card here to create a delivery when we
submit we want to redirect to the
delivery page so we need to create a
another component here which is a
delivery
.js
here I will use the shortcut
so this is the delivery component that
we want
and
what will we show inside so for the
moment I'll just display delivery here
and let's add the logic in our app.js
so
here
I will create a variable
ID set ID is equal to use state
empty string inside
so we need the ID of the delivery that
we will create we will create that
delivery from this form here and if the
ID is set we will display the delivery
component and the way that we will do it
is like this so I will add here
if I deep is equal to empty string
question mark I will show this form
otherwise I will show the delivery
component
and that should be it so in the
beginning the ID is empty so we will see
the card here but if this is something
else
we'll show the delivery here so the text
that we just wrote there and when we
submit this form
I'll create a submit function
this will be asynchronous and this will
have an event here
that we will
call prevent
default
and when we submit this form so on
submit we will call that submit function
so
here now
we will get the inputs from the form so
I will use a shorter wave so I'll create
a variable form which is equal to new
form data
inside I will pass event.target
the data
so the values the budget and the notes
will be equal to object
from entries
form
so my bad form entries like this
so this form data that and entries will
return all these number and notes so all
the inputs and if we do use it like this
it will convert it to a Json as we want
so just like this uh
like a budget
10
etc etc so this is the format that this
will return
and now we got everything that we want
the only thing left is to get the
response
which is equal to a weight
fetch
the request to create the delivery is
http
localhost Port 8000
slash deliveries
slash create
we'll pass some values here
like the method is a post request
and the headers
are like this content
type is application
Json
then we need the body which is Json
stringify
and the way that we will return we will
send the data is exactly as we did in
our Postman here so it is like this we
need the type which is create delivery
type is create delivery
and the data is this data as it is here
that's why I call it data
this will convert those values like this
Json here
and that should be it we will get a
response
and we will convert that response to
Json so we will await
response
Json like this
and that Json will contain the ID that
we want so we will set the ID
to content
or I will deconstruct it directly so we
need the ID here
and I'll set the ID directly like this
and that should be it so I will remove
this one now
and
if we go to our browser now
I'll put the budget to 50 and in the
notes Peak
two burgers
submit and we redirected to the delivery
page so that's it so this is uh
completed
I should have gotten the ID of that
delivery but let's create it again so 50
pick two burgers
submit
and this will get this object actually I
will
copy it all
oh
this is the object the ID here will be
this one
and I'll cut this
I'll create another object here
I'll call it state
and it will be equal to use state
so this state does not is not connected
with this react State here
there are different things but
this is the first state of our delivery
and I will put it directly here because
I don't want to
recreate it multiple times but later on
I will revert it back because the
default state for this will be just an
empty object
so I'll put it like this
and if I do it like this we will go
directly to the delivery page and now
let's build this page
let's go to the HTML and I will I will
replace this HTML with a div here
over the class name of row and width
100. then the second element will be a
div with a class name of call 12.
margin border form
inside I will just display an H4
with a class name of
uh
bold and text White
and this will be the delivery
and I will show here
restate.id so this will be just the
delivery ID as I show it here so which
this is a title and the next value will
be the progress bar so this is a little
bit more complicated but
this is a div
with a class name of call 12. and margin
bottom to five
and I'll add another div here
with a class name of
progress
and now we need to add the bootstrap
progress bar so how do we add it
you can check the documentation so if we
go to get bootstrap.com
in the docs we have the progress
bar
so progress
bar like this so this is what I want to
build and I want to add an animation
just like this one
so
inside the class name will be
progress bar
background success
progress
bar progress stripped
actually not like this it will be
progress bar
stripped
and progress
bar
animated
I will close this part so we can see
more code
and then I will add a role
which is
progress bar
then we need some Style
which we need to add only the width
250
percent
like this
and we need to close the div so this
will
look like this so as you can see the 50
of this bar is is looking like it is a
uh
in progress so we need a second one
and uh
now it looks like a one progress bar but
we need to show different uh animation
Styles based on different statuses so if
the status is ready then we don't want
to show any progress bar so in this case
I will do it like this
all that here if state that status
is not
ready
question mark also this progress bar
then
I will
uh not show anything
so I'll make it like this here
I will not show anything then so same
will happen for this other one but uh
I can add the same condition but it's
not the same condition so if we do it
like this the status ready is a white
bar which is correct now the next status
is
I will manually change it here it is
active
so if the status is active we need to
show the half of the progress bar here
uh in progress so how do we do that
first
for the status here I will change it so
this status here it should be either
collected
or
I'll copy
it again or completed
so this is the second half we need the
status either collected or completed
and now we'll show it like this which is
correct
nope the next part is the status is
collected
if we do it like this we can see that
the old bar is kind of animated but it
should not be like this
because the first part should not be
animated because only the second part
should be animated so for that the class
name here
I'll change it
like this
so here I will
uh check if the status it is active
question mark
if it is active then I will show this
class that we had
otherwise
I'll paste it again but I will I'll
remove this progress bar script and
animated
so if the status is active we will show
the strips and the animation style if
it's not active then it is just the
background success
and this will make it look like this so
it seems like the first part is
completed
only the second part is not completed
and now the status is collected and this
is the correct animation
and the last status is completed
completed
which in this case this should be all
green and the logic will be similar to
this one that we just copied
I will paste it here
except the difference is the status that
we will compare it
is a
completed
and that should be it so
did I make mistakers or something
collected actually
now it is correct so
that's it for the statuses so we have a
lot of conditions here but the main
thing that I wanted to show is if the
status is ready
then we show a white bar if the status
is active
we show the first part is in progress
if the status is collected
the first part is the green and the
second part is in progress and the last
one is completed
which is all green so these are all
animations that I wanted
now let's add the events so we need some
kind of events to trigger these
animations so for that I will add here
another div
with a class name of
called
3 here
inside I will add the card so I'll copy
the card from
this
form here it will be almost similar and
I'll paste it here
so the difference is that this is start
delivery
and it won't have any inputs
and I will add later the on submit
button
so if I add this
uh it seems I have a problem here
now it should be correct
we can see the start delivery event here
so let's add the more events the second
one is
increased budget
and
this time we need an input
I'll paste it directly
so we need a number input
uh that uh says the budget so this is a
second event I'll copy this
paste it again and the other event will
be
pick up
products
and for the inputs here I'll paste them
again
we will have two inputs one is the
purchase price and the second one is the
quantity
and I'll copy this again to add the last
event which is the deliver
products and the only difference here
this is a sell price
and this is cell price
and that's it so these are the four
events that we will work with
and they will all submit to the same
function so let's create that submit
function here
is equal to
in a synchronous function this will have
an event and the event will have
a
prevent default
now here I can copy the code from app.js
so this part here it is almost the same
let's go back
and I'll paste it here so we will get
the form here we will get the data so
these are the inputs if we have any of
them if we don't have that's not a
problem
the event will be on the
event here so that it was the wrong
endpoint
a method post the headers are correct
and the type will be different so the
problem here is the type because each
event has a different type there but we
can pass the type in the function here
directly
and I can remove it here so when I send
the request uh the type will be dynamic
and it will work like this
so let's go to the first one start
delivery we will have on submit here
we'll have an event but we will call a
submit function with the event and the
type will be start delivery
so this is the difference when we submit
we will call all the same function only
the type will change I'll copy this
I'll paste it here and this is increased
budget so increase
budget
same for the other one
this is pickup
products
and the last one is
delivered
products
and that's it so all of these functions
will send
almost the same events but with
different types and we need also to
handle the response how do we handle the
response
first I will add the condition here if
the response
is not okay so we get an error
validation error then we will get
the detail
from the response which is equal await
a response
Json here
and we will simply alert that detail
and we will return
otherwise we will
refresh the state so
about the state we didn't add here use
the effect
so
for the moment I want to do anything
here in this user effect but I will go
back to our app.js because we are
getting a manual delivery here
uh we need to pass that ID to this
delivery object so like this so ID is
equal to that ID
and if we pass it like that
in our delivery.js here
I'll add the an asynchronous function
that calls
the status endpoint so like this
here I'll get a response
which is equal to 08
fetch
and the end point that we want to call
here is HTTP localhost Port 8000
slash deliveries
and I'll change the quotes here to this
backtics
I need to pass here the ID
that we sent from our app.js so we need
the props here
and this value will be props.id
and this is the status
so this is how we get the current status
the data so let me close this
data is equal to weight response.json
and we will set the state to this data
like this and we don't need this values
that we set before so with this user
effect we can directly get the state
that we want and in our app.js
we can remove this one also because
once we create a new delivery
we will pass it directly here so
that should be it let's see how our app
will work now let's add the budget as
well with 50 and pick two burgers
and deliver to customer
submit
as we can see once we submit we get the
ID we deliver we move to the delivery
page and we have a lot of statuses so
here I forgot to add also another thing
which is to show the Json
I'll go to the delivery.js
and here
I will show
the Json
like this so div
all that here a class name of call 12.
and margin top four
and I will show
uh
so this is not a div here this is a code
and inside I will show Json stringify
the state
like this so if I add this line in the
end we can see the actual State at the
bottom so this is the object that we
just created
and now we want to start the delivery
and when we submit we want also to
update this uh
[Music]
progress bar
how can we do that so uh
we can do that by calling the state
again once this request has finished and
the only way to do that is to add
another variable here refresh
set refresh
is equal to use State false it doesn't
matter if it is false or true but I will
add here refresh
and once this value changes we will get
the new state so if the response is not
okay we will display an alert if it is
okay
I will set refresh
to the opposite of refresh
so basically I want to
uh get the status again and that should
be it so let's click now start delivery
it should work actually why it didn't
work
so now that I check the Json that we
sent we forgot to send something so the
thing that we forgot to send
in this submit function is the delivery
ID that we are so that is my mistake so
we are we forgot to add here the
delivery
ID which is the state
dot ID like this and now we can test it
again
and as you can see the first part is
animated the status has become active
and now let's pick up products so
uh
two products with the price of 20.
submit and as you can see this part is
completed this is in progress the
purchase price is 20 and the quantity is
2. we can deliver the products we can
sell with a higher price quantity submit
and it is successful so the first case
worked just fine
so that's it now all the refresh again
and let's create another delivery so the
budget now is again 50.
and now we speak
three ice creams
and let's submit so as you can see
everything is working correctly let's
start the delivery and let's start it
again so
now we are alerting error so the
delivery has already started and we
cannot start it again so this is working
fine
what happens now when we pick
three products but we don't have enough
budget let's submit not enough budget so
what do we do
we may increase the budget so I will
increase the budget with 20. submit and
now the new budget has been increased
and now if we pick up the products with
these values
it should be not a problem and now let's
deliver these products so
a higher price and the quantity will be
four
we have another problem now not enough
quantity so it should be three
and now it is successful so this is the
simplest way of an event-driven
architecture I hope you learned a lot of
things from this tutorial thank you for
watching and don't forget to like share
and subscribe thank you